you want to hear a story about how me
and this [ __ ] fell out
it's kind of long but it's felicia's
face
well first thing i have to ask is since
this is where it all started off
i want to start with y'all on when you
read the viral thread i know both of
y'all are on twitter
and then what was your reaction and
taylor i'll start with you yeah so
unfortunately i wasn't a part of that
moment the period piece
2015. i i was peer pressured into
getting a twitter in 2009
and would literally just like tweet some
random positive [ __ ] and log out
so i didn't i wasn't in real i didn't i
wasn't like a scroller so i didn't know
about the tweet until i found out i was
auditioning for it and wanted more
context and was like holy
and um i mean it's pretty it's pretty
incredible
yeah we're here because of it so
seriously
look what she birthed uh riley what
about you what was your first reaction
when you saw it and
and yeah when was the first time you did
see it well i was lucky enough to
read it in real time in 2015 when it
came out somebody sent it to me
and i was just like everybody else like
once you pick it up you can't stop
reading it it's incredibly compelling
and
her writing is amazing and the way she
describes all these insane characters is
just like you can't
put it down so i'm i feel i was really
happy that i was able to experience that
before doing the movie
yeah and now look at it later you guys
are playing a part in it which i think
is so crazy this is like such a movie of
the internet
age and like meme culture and just
vibrality
and it makes me think like i have to put
it to zola i think she has like
like hall of fame top like viral moment
but
just to let the internet have its day
what's been your favorite one like
the guy of recently that was the cat
with the filter
i laughed at that for like eight years
oh on the zoom meeting
yes oh no wait that one is in court
right yeah it was like
oh my gosh i'm from texas that just
spoke to me on a level
like yeah i'm not a cat or something
yes so that was a favorite one of mine
recently what was your favorite one of
y'alls and it can be anything it can be
random the internet gives us so much
riley i'll start with you oh my gosh
wait what
let me think i don't even know i mean
that's a really hard question the amount
of memes i get a day
like from my husband and from my friends
is like probably engenixa
actually yeah is a crazy
amazing binder she's a great
meme dmr um i think it's so hard i i get
so much
content every day it's like i can't even
remember like what i got this morning
but
taylor do you got one i can't think of a
meme off the top but like i am obsessed
with this girl young barbecue
who just like makes me laugh she kind of
like lowers my blood pressure
i love people like you know young
barbecue no i don't but i'm going to
look her up immediately
yeah young it's y-u-n-g-bbq
i'm on it love this i love when people
give you new aspects of the internet i'm
glad you guys brought up to nixa because
i mean
honestly follow janixa anyone who
doesn't also follow
zola on twitter yeah and even on
instagram on instagram
because yeah yeah like you're in for a
treat
but i want y'all to talk about working
with her because i know this from
talking with folks that did lemon and
some of her shorts she's just such
like her spirit is just also how she
directs and there's just so much of
herself that she puts into it and i find
that all the actors i've talked to that
worked with her fall in love with her a
little bit so yeah
talk about working with her um and
taylor i'll start with you
yeah definitely in love with her i mean
i think that i feel
almost like in a surreal way like wow
like you must think i'm
smart enough to be in your ether if
you're including me because she's just
so
freaking smart and pays attention to
every detail
and has such care and wisdom and funny
experiences and
that she's able to share and express in
a really
special way and
she's just like she's just an artist
through and through everything she does
is just so intentional her home
just like she's just a cutie pie i don't
know i just like adore her and i want
she i'm always like i tease when i like
have been at her house and like one day
i'll be a grown woman enough to like
have cute napkins like this but i say
that all to say that she just
her deep care for just like making
everything art i feel is like just
really
inspiring that's the thing making
everything art and both of you have
worked with
incredible directors um throughout your
career but yeah riley
what about you what would you take away
from your time on set with janixa
the thing for me about janixa is it just
feels like such an
honor to be in a
piece of her work like she's such a
genius
and she's you feel like you're in the
presence of greatness
and it's exciting and exhilarating and
um just an
honor she's she's incredible and i
have only felt like that a couple times
in my whatever amount of movies i've
done and she has
everything's right everything's
everything she's she's everything she's
good at everything you know it's like
the aesthetic's incredible her um
her director acting her directing
her directing of actors is incredible
her
um writing is incredible like she's just
incredible at everything when she speaks
it's incredible
when she's giving a speech is incredible
when she's
just talking at the dinner table it's
incredible she's just this walking yeah
like she's a walking genius and it's
just so
fun to like be in her presence and yeah
um
be a part of her film i love that living
it um
i'm gonna talk to uh you taylor a bit
about your time with zola because that's
so
i mean granted this is a fictional
adaptation but this is a real person
and it came from her and it feels so
personal
i mean what was your time like with her
and how
how did you navigate that because i
would like never want to speak to her be
like i just need to go do this and
pretend you're not real
but i'm sure you guys got really close
yeah i mean we didn't get to meet until
sundance but we talked a lot like we
text dm'd a lot and we're kind of going
through some similar life experiences
like both of our cars broke down
and you know being having these lulls
where she's been waiting for this movie
to be made and
being an actor is a roller coaster you
know it's ups and downs it's
getting to the final round and getting a
lot of no's
and i think we like just leaned on one
another and confided in one another and
i felt really
just like blessed that she felt that i
could
do it and that she was she was down for
me to play her
like i had her blessing and but yeah i
just wanted to make sure
because at the time she wasn't actually
as active on
her her instagram presence wasn't as she
didn't have a lot of videos or
like i really only had like the tmz her
tmz article and like one other thing
that i found but
i just wanted to like get her walk down
and her voice
and her eyes and like
you know it's like being just really
uh caring of like though this movie
exists as hyperbolic like hype it's
hyperbolas it's like
zola's social media presence is also a
character that she plays
and so in in this move
in this in our film like her subdued
engaged observing is also
like a big part of who zola is and why
she's so smart
in real life is this what you came here
for
do it look like i came for this i guess
i have to ask everybody this
because it's where it all started but
when did you come across the viral
thread was it just
when you were reading for this or did
you see it when it happened
it was just when i was sent the project
um they sent me the script and then they
sent the twitter thread along with it
and so i i read the twitter thread first
um and yeah i felt kind of stupid
because like it see
everyone that i talked to is like you
didn't you didn't read that when it came
out
i was reading it the day that it came
out i was following every tweet as it
came out
so there's so many people that were
really hooked into this
um and i wasn't but but yeah
you know it just was it was just a sort
of shocking piece of literature
reading you know reading that that that
thing
bang bang bang bang bang yeah we all
breathlessly read it i did like but
i got it the next day it was very much
like oh my lord this is the thing
but it's like a great moment of internet
virality
and as someone who knows a little bit
about doing things on the internet that
kind of pop off i'm just curious if you
have a favorite
like either meme or viral moment like
recently there was the dude with
the lens with the cat from texas and i'm
from texas and that one just hit me in a
place like i will
play that video over again and i will
always laugh do you have something like
that that you like go back to
oh man um i don't
i i like memes but i never they go
right out of my brain like jokes like
i can't remember jokes and tell retell a
joke
uh i like them but they go straight
through so i feel like that's
me and like beams and gifs and things
like that
even videos do you have like a favorite
video maybe that you go back to and
you're just like okay if i'm feeling sad
i can pull this one up and giggle
i feel like any time i watch nathan
fielder um
you know yeah like anything for you
stuff yeah if i rewatch an episode of
nathan for you that brings me
a lot of joy i like that one um
it's kind of interesting to like i feel
like folks when they see this they're
definitely going to make it synonymous
and of course
a lot of folks got to know you first
time with succession but
of the two characters who do you think
is in a more dangerous situation because
they both seem to be guileless people
in like nests full of vipers but which
one do you think is in worst trouble
your character in this or cousin greg
that's a
really good question um they bar
they both are definitely in danger uh
well i guess the danger is realized in
zola
for derek um you know this is the worst
this is
like the worst moment of his life so i i
would
say i would say him because he actually
i think he
doesn't have quite the i think greg's
much smarter
um and so derek
doesn't really see things coming as
clearly as a as greg might
and and therefore ends up you know on
this trip
and um basic basically goes through hell
so greg's going through a slow hell
oh previews next season
i'm going to take that as gospel um
there's another aspect i think of
working with this and that's working
with genixa
from everyone that i've spoken to she's
just a singular director in so many ways
just from like how she
talks to the actors and sort of the way
she adds her own particular style if you
could just talk a little
bit about working with her and what you
took from it
yeah um janixa
definitely is singular you know she she
had a style in mind she had colors in
mine and costume
and um the first
time i met her we had a great
conversation we really
got down on all the same things in this
movie that
we both loved and then she sent me her
dramaturgy for the movie and all of her
tonal references and pictures i mean
sometimes i go back to that because
for whatever reason the link is still
good um and
and it's just folders and folders and
hundreds of images
that she wanted to somehow convey in
in this movie whether it's a tiny thing
lipstick a lipstick a specific lipstick
or
you know blood splatter on a shirt um
so she she's just a really special
person in that way
uh and and so when we were on set
even though you know we weren't trying
to emulate a photo or something it was
like
all of that is inside of this movie all
of those intentions are inside of it
i love that um i have to ask this one
again because this is an internet movie
and you've had a moment at the early
parts of the pandemic with two you have
the antibodies
now that folks are getting vaccinated as
also maybe like
a way to usher in this next chapter are
you gonna do a remix or a chapter two
about do you have the vaccine like i
feel like that's the natural progression
i thought about it i thought about it
but
i just didn't you know it was such a
fun trip that whole antibodies
experience
you know going from just a video i put
up that i thought people would maybe
laugh at
but then it turned into a whole musical
thing and
getting a deal with atlantic records and
like the whole thing was
ju designing merch um it was
just crazy and i thought covers the
covers like the company contest
so hundreds of people sending their own
versions
which are included in the music video
you know it just felt like
that's it you know and people have been
listening to it for
for vaccine related purposes so that was
cool that
it got a second life for that but uh
i couldn't re i can't write another
pandemic song
one i'm i'm maxed out no hey look you
you gave that to the world at the
perfect time and it was honestly like it
was like the perfect
song for the perfect moment so i like
appreciate the idea of like look
i'm not gonna top this and i'm totally
out on it like i'm with that
i'm just gonna throw this one out here
too because this is like i think i
called it uh fear and loathing in las
vegas on clear heels when i when i
tweeted about it because it's very much
a
crazy road trip movie i'm just curious
if you have
one of those or like a destination like
you don't have to give me details about
all the stuff you did especially if it's
incriminating but like what
what's that crazy road trip for you um
i had a i did a road trip where i
where i drove from la
to san francisco to colorado new mexico
and i ended up in new orleans
and i would just say
without going too deep into it um
new orleans just you just rage in new
orleans you can't
not rage i've also been there for
bachelor parties that were
incredible times with friends and
you know i think i was kissing one of my
friends on the mouth like one of my
buddies
like just like kind of making out with
him on the street and
all of our friends around and like
filming and we were like we're best
friends like this is what best friends
do
and um so you know it was like
i look back on that trip with with that
group of friends and i'm
i mean that is like it just makes me fee
it's i don't know you get what i'm
saying it was like one of those
i'm from texas and new orleans is our
vegas so
i know new orleans is sometimes more
dangerous in that respect too
so thank you very much and to be clear
i'll kiss that friend
any day but it was better in new orleans
sis why are you tagging me in photos you
don't even [ __ ] with me
let me know let me know yes it is
hi y'all jaclyn from rotten tomatoes so
excited for this interview
um janiksa i'm going to start with you
ma'am i have to ask everyone this about
when was the first time
you saw the viral thread that has
brought us all here today
2015. i said the night
of the day that it came out i was on a
group thread with three black
girlfriends
and i think i was on a job that day i
had to have been on a
on a set that day i i used to be a
stylist because i remember looking at my
phone
and uh the the image or the icon
said something like um 120
missed text messages and when i opened
my email or i opened my text rather
uh all like 112 of those are just in one
group chat which i i don't want to open
because i'm like i don't have the time
to get into this
uh so i got to it that night and it was
in my three girlfriends you know sending
each other each of the tweets and then
all of their responses so the way that i
read it was like
reading the tweet and then how my
friends interacted with each of them and
it was like
a novel within the novel within the
cobbles it was like a nesting doll
and i before i was done reading it just
was like oh i have to tell this story i
don't know why but i'm just supposed to
i've been i've been told
it's been said to me for this reason um
also shout out to a group thread with
black women it will literally save lives
i can tell you that for sure obama's
group thread all the time i'm just like
who
is in that right seriously oh god you
just made me jealous instantly
jeremy what about you sir when did you
come across the thread
um and how was your first reaction well
i mean jacqueline you know this because
you've seen me probably but i am a big
twitter user
and so i was like on twitter
[Music]
janice doesn't like it because i send
her all the tweets about us i'm like oh
my god look what they said look what
they said
anyway um i'm i'm like the opposite of
that really sweet black girl group chat
it's just like i'm just sending tweets
like look at this evil thing someone
said about our movie aren't they crazy
she's like why do i want to read this
anyway i saw this twitter i saw the
thread
um while it was happening and asia
doesn't remember this but she responded
to me
but i was like i like tweeted at her and
she tweeted back at me and i was like oh
my god
and then like in the middle of the thing
i was there live
watching it and i similarly to janixa
went around telling all of my friends i
would do live read something from my
friends
and in my best you know like
undergraduate theater voice
and they were like jeremy you have to do
something that sounds like i know like
i really want to write it but like how
will it ever happen like i don't even
have an agent yet
um and then luckily i met this woman and
everything changed a couple years later
i can't wait to talk about youtube
writing this together but
zola again this all started with you but
i just have to talk about
you in the moment of like when first of
all you knew this is not just like a
viral thing
that's gonna be like a fun thing for the
weekend like this is different
and then just like what was that moment
for you just
watching folks like missy elliott and
like all of these
other like it became like it was like
this was the only thing black folks
talked about
for like weeks that part was fun i was
like
okay girl but um in the beginning
i'ma say while i was tweeting it while
it was going viral
because i had never really witnessed
that
in to that you know to that extent
like it was like every tweet in itself
was going viral so that was different
for me
um but it kind of gave me like a live
audience so they fed
me a lot of energy and that's why i kept
going i'm like
okay i got i got an audience here i
can't let my audience down in the middle
of the show
so um that kind of helps it become what
it is
um and then like overnight like you said
missy elliott
and jack k and it was it was like uh
all of the black women who i've always
kind of looked up to
were like giving me a pat on the back
and i'm like okay i think i did
something here
like so yeah i love that i i
i'm still in shock i'm like don't you
can't tell me nothing missy elliot knows
who i am you can't tell me anything
seriously if missy elliot before i was i
would be exactly the same
seriously um i'm going to start with you
jennifer
too and both jeremy because this is
first of all obviously the movie is just
quintessentially an authentically black
and just like has no apologies about it
but it's such a movie of the internet
and y'all did so many things to make it
feel
like it was when we were scrolling and
from the dings
and and sort of the the way that people
spoke in a heightened version of way you
figure folks would speak with that
how much of that was on the page and
when did you guys decide to add so much
of the internet aspect of it to it and
was that difficult maybe i think for
maybe folks to buy into because i'm sure
some people would be like what's with
the dates
the datings were written in actually uh
there's a i think it's early
in the script there was like an asterix
that was
anytime a line in the dialogue
is directly pulled from the twitter
thread
there will be a twitter whistle in
homage
of its source material and sometimes
they're written in but sometimes they
also fade away or they have the asterisk
so that if you remember having read that
slug you know
40 pages ago you'll know what that that
that was a part of it
but it was also their release so that
like when my editor read the script when
our composer read the script that they
knew that there was going to be
this like sonic aspect to the film
that would be woven into the narrative
even if like on the page you can't
process a whistle
you know that there is this thing that
happens
after right like there's even a scroll
written
into the script that then happens
in post like these are these are
editorial things but i wanted them to be
in there so that we could
kind of mimic or or mirror some of the
electricness or the electricity
of what happens within the internet and
within
a space like twitter yeah and you
definitely felt that um
jeremy i have to bring it to you because
correct me if i'm wrong but
y'all were passing the script um while
you were still at yale as sort of like a
logic file
between you and janice obviously writing
it together but separately
and i just want to talk about what
that's like because in itself it's like
the script was even written
over the internet in a way no it was
and you know i think that like thinking
about like why some of the sort of
internetiness
was there um it kind of came from that
sort of scrappiness that has that
happens
that makes innovation happen impossible
on in digital landscapes right
um because you know we were doing this
so far apart
there was a wild time crunch because we
really like you know like everyone have
been waiting for this movie to get
started for a while
and we were getting all these insane
notes all the time
that we were having to process too coast
apart like
over the internet over phone calls and
really they say
they want more energy what is energy
even you're like how do we do this and
that
and you know and i think that so much of
what made it
feel right was us getting on the phone
and saying like but what what okay
when we see this scene what will make it
feel like a meme
of jim so i remember there were like
three different ways that we wrote
um how nick or that nick but derek
would end up like uh falling out of the
um
uh out of the window because we knew we
wanted to feel iconic as iconic as it
felt in the tweet
because the thing we kept going back to
as co-writers even
all of this space apart was like how
do we make each tweet habits do
because actually like you said asia did
go viral every tweet
was a tweet that like was retweeted so
lost in the sauce is not something we
can just like
have lost in the sauce and yeah that was
the sort of manicness
of our script and the sort of um
innovations of our script came from the
fact that i was truly
still a student janixa was fully
directing other tv shows and
like in and doing um a press for her
film that had just come out
while we were trying to build this new
thing together
i came to dance no no no we're done with
[Music]
that
you